the whistleblowers attorney also says he
fears for his clients safety because of
some of the reaction to the report it
has been significant Paula Reid is at
the White House for us Paula how's the
president handling all this a good
morning Tony the president says he
deserves to meet the whistleblower but
there is no right to confront your
accuser in an impeachment inquiry this
is not a court of law this is a
political process and that's why over
the weekend we saw the president's
advisors taking their case to the court
of public opinion this individual is a
saboteur trying to undermine a
democratically elected government the
president's allies appeared on the
Sunday political shows to attack the
whistleblower who set off an impeachment
inquiry there were a lot of things if
you read the whistleblower report that
are concerning in terms of allegations
that were very partisan they continued
to dismiss the allegations as secondhand
knowledge even though most of the
details are corroborated by a partial
record of the call released by the White
House I think this whole thing is a sham
I can't believe we're talking about
impeaching the president based on an
accusation based on hearsay who is this
whistleblower what buys to the head
President Trump appeared to make a
veiled threat against the intelligence
official tweeting I want to meet not
only my accuser but also the person who
illegally gave this information adding
was this person spying on the US
president big consequences the rhetoric
is raising concerns about the
whistleblower safety I believe that the
whistleblower and the Inspector General
have acted in good faith throughout in a
letter to acting intelligence Chief
Joseph Maguire an attorney for the
whistleblower voiced serious concerns
for his client's personal safety citing
these comments by President Trump at a
private event last week
[Music]
the attorney also indicated a $50,000
bounty has been issued for information
relating to his clients identity button
played a role in getting these collusion
allegations covered up the president's
advisors still cannot answer questions
about why Giuliani was reaching out to
Ukraine and not US law enforcement if
these charges are so serious and so
credible why are they not being picked
up by the president's hand-picked FBI
director the president's hand the
Attorney General I don't see they
haven't I don't know if they have done
or they haven't in that July call
President Trump told the Ukrainian
leader that he would have Giuliani or
attorney General William bar reach out a
CBS News has learned that the Attorney
General was surprised and angry to be
lumped in with Giuliani
as it suggests that the president's
personal attorney and the nation's top
law enforcement official have the same
role Gail so many layers thank you very
much Paula